sometimes budget phones are more
exciting to review than Flagship phones
especially when you have a phone like
this that comes at a price point that is
far less than what you expect it to be
it has specs that are rivaling some
Flagship phones out to the market I'm
talking about the Poco X5 Pro 5G I've
had this in my hands for the past couple
weeks of course it has been announced
today the Embargo is up for us here at
least in Singapore and I gotta tell you
this is a very very impressive phone
especially for the price point this
comes in around 469 Singapore dollars
which I believe is going to be around
300 or 325 USD depending on the
conversion rate and you are getting a
6.67 inch fhd plus AMOLED display you're
getting eight gigabytes of RAM 256
gigabytes of onboard storage there's
also a six gigabyte 128 version as well
which is slightly less expensive I have
the eight gigabyte version with me
you're having Dolby Vision Dolby Atmos
You've Got High refresh rate 120 hertz
refresh rate on this you've got quick
recharging a 67 watt charger inside the
Box you've got a really nice build
quality 108 megapixel camera eight
megapixel for the wide and two megapixel
for the macro MIUI 14 which is basically
xiaomi's latest UI for their Android 5
000 milliamp battery life that is the
same battery that is in the all-new s23
Ultra which I'm testing out right now by
the way Fantastic Four and all coming in
at a price point of 469 Singapore
dollars or 300 325 USD this video is
brought to you by MSI meet the summit E6
then flip featuring the latest 12th gen
Intel Core i7 processor RTX 30 series
graphics and a 16 inch Quad HD Plus
touchscreen panel with a 360 degree
hinge it lets you unleash maximum
productivity with up to 11 hours of
battery life at just 2 kilograms the
summit e16 flip offers unprecedented
performance and functionality allowing
you to work and play anywhere anytime so
this is what 4K 30 looks like on the
Poco high profile G now there is no
steady video mode on this when you hit
steady video you go to 1080. but the
phone itself does have some
stabilization inside of it as you can
tell by the background now you're going
to notice the colors are a little more
vibrant a little bit more saturated
maybe a little too much depending on
your likes or dislikes for me it is a
bit
a little bit over the top but I
definitely could still use this it's a
very bright outside hence why I'm
squinting I probably need sunglasses but
just giving you an idea how the
microphone sounds and also how the video
called is on this now we're going to
switch to the front facing camera so
here's the front facing camera and we
can only go 1080 as all xiaomi phones
are regardless Poco or not but
stabilization is still pretty good on
this not too bad one day one day xiaomi
will get to 4K for the front-facing
camera not yet but so far so good I
would say the colors look a little bit
less saturated could be just the phone
screen a little bit less saturated on
the front facing camera than on the rear
but we'll find out when I throw this
into a final cut for the video editing
talking about photos for a second let's
talk about that night mode works
relatively well you're going to notice
some flaring coming from the lenses
sometimes from street lights that's
something that you are going to notice
and I would say overall the image
quality is really good portrait mode is
surprisingly really good I really like
what portrait mode how it performed I
mean it really did show up separate the
subject from the background in a very
natural way and of course you can't
adjust the aperture 108 megapixel mode
works great as well a lot of great
details so yeah I have to say I'm very
impressed with the photos that this
camera takes again slightly saturated
but that is something you can adjust in
Lightroom or Capture One or whatever
software you're using whereas video may
be a little bit less even though it's
h.265 you might have a little bit less
flexibility on video anyway back to the
review this is exciting because you know
get a phone in your hands like this that
cost this low and it does a lot of
things really well and I'm not just
creating Samsung by the way but why does
it feel like this have to be almost over
2 000 Singapore dollars or the iPhone 14
pro Max which is well over 2000 plus
Singapore dollars now these are both
great phones but a phone like this can
come in 469 and give you a lot of
performance not exactly the same and I'm
not going to say it's exactly the same
but a lot of the performance that these
two phones can give you
at a third of the price or an eighth of
the price or whatever it may be my math
I'm not afraid of math but you know what
I'm saying that's where this really
comes into play and I'm going to talk a
little bit about the phone the features
what it's like to use I'm not going to
go too in depth because it is you know
it is part and parcel pretty much if I
was to compare this to a phone that we
might have used if you're used to xiaomi
phones maybe the me 11 or the me 10 uh
Pro or the protea or whatever they call
them these days because they got various
different names it's in that ballpark so
it's probably a couple years old in
terms of Technology when you look at it
that it's still relevant today even with
the Snapdragon 778g processor which is
pretty much the same that is in the
nothing phone one I would definitely get
this phone over the nothing phone one
hands down wouldn't even think twice
this is Better Built got this really
cool light display in the back of it it
feels great it feels it almost sounds
like an iPhone build quality to it
really well done the cameras on this
aren't that good can't even face unlock
it doesn't recognize my face no matter
how many times I do it I mean firmware
update or not doesn't really recognize
this works on a variety of different
levels now in terms of the build quality
the back of this is more of a plastic
feel to it it does feel a little bit
less expensive um I like the two-tone
colors on this you got yellow and black
you also have a blue and you have a
Black Version out there I kind of like
the yellow and black it's got a little
bit of a bumblebee Vibe you got this uh
yellow power button there as well it's
very lightweight 181 grams easy to put
into the pocket you forget it's even
there
um the size is really good at 6.67
inches I mentioned earlier now it's an
fhd plus display so it's around 2400 by
1080. to be honest with you most content
that we watch on our phones nowadays
isn't even 4K it's 1080 or 720. so when
you're watching YouTube videos or you
know podcasts on Spotify what have you
or even your tick tocks or Instagram
reels this is fine you're not going to
miss a beat get your P3 cover damage
srgb color in this you've got the Dolby
Vision that kicks on when you need to
Dolby Atmos or Dolby sound whatever it
is it all sounds good now the speakers
on this don't sound as Bassy as let's
say the iPhone or the Samsung for that
matter that's where you're gonna get you
know pay a little extra money Gonna Get
Better Sound out of this the speakers
sound a little bit more they're pushing
the treble a bit more there's like a
bass but you can customize a little bit
in The Equalizer but it's still not as
good as some of the other phones but
it's loud uh what else battery life on
this is fantastic more than a day usage
easily more than a day day and a half
and you can charge from zero to thirty
percent in seven minutes because xiaomi
or say Poco for that matter but it's a
subdivision I'll show me anyway still
gives you a charger in the box and they
don't ask you to buy another one but
they're giving you a 67 watt charger in
the box which can easily charge other
devices that you have whereas other
manufacturers who want to be
eco-friendly but they actually want you
to pay more because you know their
phones become more powerful you need
fast charging so you have to buy another
charger they don't include them in the
box and they charge you a premium
xiaomi says we're going to give you the
charger in the box with this
Food For Thought isn't it's very
interesting how some of these phone
manufacturers work that's a topic for
another discussion and another day but I
will tell you
what you get for this phone if you're
looking for a secondary phone backup
phone maybe times have been tough with
inflation you know job security isn't
there you're like look I need to get a
new smartphone but I don't know what I
get I don't have a lot of money right
now don't feel bad honestly some of
these phones to me personally have
gotten way out of line in terms of price
points yes there's a lot of great
technology in them but they're very very
expensive but if you need something
that's going to tide you over that's
going to give you good image quality to
take photos with you can do your videos
you can do your Instagram reels your
tick tocks you can take phone calls it's
going to last you all day in terms of
battery life and you're not going to
break the bank check this out if you
like this review subscribe to the
channel and check out more of our videos
right here
foreign